The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Today's lecture's full of
tries and trays, and trees.
Oh, my.
Lots of different synonyms
all coming from trees.
In particular,
we're going to cover
suffix trees today and various
representations of them,
and how to build
them in linear time.
Now, they are good things.
Some of you may have
seen suffix trees before,
but hopefully, haven't actually
seen most of the things
we're going to cover,
except for the very basics.
So the general problem we're
interested in solving today
is string matching.
And in string matching
we are given two strings.
One of them we call the
text T and the other one
we call a pattern P.
These are both strings
over some alphabet.
And the alphabet we're going
to always call capital Sigma.
Think of that.
It could be binary--
0 and 1.
Could be ASCII, so there's
256 characters in there.
Could be Unicode-- pick
your favorite alphabet.
Then it could be ACGT for DNA.
And their goal is to
find the occurrences
of the pattern in the text.
Could be we want to find
some of those occurrences
or all of them, or count them.
And in this lecture, we're
only interested in substring
searches.
So the pattern is just a string.
You want to know all the
places where P occurs.
P might appear multiple times,
even overlapping itself--
in those two
positions, whatever.
You want to find all the shifts
of P where it's identical to T.
Now, there are
lots of variations
on this problem
which we won't look
at in this lecture, such as
when the pattern has wildcards
in it, or you could imagine
it being a regular expression,
or you don't want
to match exactly,
you want to match approximately,
you could have some mismatches,
or it could require
some edits to match
T. We're not going to
look at those problems.
This is both an algorithmic
problem and a data structures
problem.
If I give you this
text in the pattern,
I just want to know the answer.
You can do that in
linear time-- it's
famous Knuth-Morris-Pratt, or
Boyer-Moore, or Rabin-Karp.
Lots of linear time
algorithms for doing that.
We're interested in
the data structure
version of the problem,
static data structure.
So we're given
the text up front,
given T. We want
to preprocess T.
And then the query
consists of the pattern.
Imagine T being very
big, P being not so big.
And we'd like to spend
something like order
P time to do a query.
That would be ideal because
you have to at least look
at the query and
you don't really
want to spend time
looking at the text.
You'd also like something
like order T space.
We don't want the space
of the data structure
to be much bigger than
the original text.
So these are goals which we will
more or less achieve, depending
on exactly the problem you want.
Sometimes we'll
achieve this, sometimes
we'll achieve almost this.
But these are really nice
running times and space.
It's all optimal.
Before we get to
that problem, I want
to solve a simpler problem which
is necessary to solve this one.
We'll call it a warm up.
And that's a good friend--
the predecessor problem,
but now among strings.
Let's say we have k strings--
k texts-- T1 to T k.
And now the query is
you're given some pattern P
and you want to
know where P fits
among these strings
in lexical order.
So a regular predecessor,
but now comparison
is string comparison.
Of course, you could try to
solve that using our existing
predecessor data structures.
But they won't do very well.
Even a binary search
tree is not going
to do well here because
comparing two strings
could take a very long time
if those strings are long.
So we don't want to do that.
Instead, we're going
to build a trie.
Now, tries we've
seen in fast sorting
lecture, when w is at least
logs at two plus epsilon event.
We used tries in a
particular setting there.
We're going to use them in
their more native setting
today a lot.
In this setting-- again,
a trie is a rooted tree.
The children
branches are labeled.
And in this case,
they're labeled
with letters in the alphabet--
Sigma.
So you have a node.
And let's say, we have the
English alphabet-- a, b,
up to z.
Those are your 26
possible children.
Some of them may not exist,
they are null pointers.
Others may point
to actual nodes.
That is a trie in
its native setting,
which is when the alphabet
is something you care about.
Now, when we used tries
before, our alphabet
just represented some
digit in some kind
of arbitrary representation.
The digit was made up of
log to the epsilon bits.
We were just using it as a tool.
But this is where
tries actually come
from-- they come from trying
to retrieve strings out
of some database, in this case.
We're doing predecessor--
this is a practical problem.
Like a lot of library
search engines,
you type in the beginning
of the title of a book
and you want to know what is the
preceding and succeeding book
title of what you query for.
So this is something
people care about.
Although really they
want us-- typically,
we want to solve this
problem because it's harder.
So that's a trie.
Now, to make this actually
work, what we'd like to do
is represent our strings.
So how do we use this structure
to represent strings T1 to T k?
We're going to
represent those strings
in the obvious way, which
we've done many times
in the past when we were doing
integer data structures--
as root to leaf paths.
Because any root to leaf path
is just a sequence of letters,
and that's a string.
So we just throw them in there.
Now, to do that, we need to
change things a little bit.
We're going to add a new letter,
which we usually present as $
sign, to the end
of every string.
I have an example.
We're going to do four strings--
various spellings
of Anna and Ann.
And say, we'd like to
throw these into a trie.
They all start with a.
So at the root, there's going to
be four branches corresponding
to $ sign, a, e, and n.
I'm supposing my
alphabet is just a,
e, n because that's
all that appears here.
But everything will
be on the a branch.
And then from there
we're going to have--
let's see-- they
all go to n next.
So they all follow this branch.
Then one of them goes to a.
These all go to n afterwards.
So we've got $ sign,
a we use, e, n we use.
And on the a
branch, we are done.
This corresponds to and a, n, e.
We're finished.
And we imagine there being $
sign at the end of this string.
So we follow the $ sign child.
The others are blank.
And this leaf here
corresponds to a, n, a.
On the other hand, if
we could do a, n, n,
there's three options.
We could be done.
Or there could be an
a or an e to follow.
So if we're done, that would
correspond to the $ sign
pointer.
That's going to be a leaf
corresponding to this string
here.
Or it could be an a
and then we're done.
And then we have a
leaf corresponding
to Anna, a, n, n, a.
Or could be we have an e
next and then we're done.
OK.
Not very exciting
but that is the tri
representation of a, n, a; a,
n, n; a, n, n, a; a, n, n, e.
And you can see there is exactly
one leaf per word down here.
And furthermore, if you
take in order traversal
of those leaves, you get
these strings in order.
And typically, if you're
going to store a data
structure like this, you would
store these actual pointers.
So once you get to a leaf,
you know which word matched.
So that's a trie.
Seems pretty trivial.
Trievial?
But it turns out there's
something already
pretty interesting about
this data structure.
How do you do a
predecessor search?
If I'm searching for something
like, I don't know, a, n, e--
because I made a typo--
then I follow a, n, and then
I follow this e branch here
and discover-- whoops--
there's nothing here.
But right at that node I see,
OK, well, my predecessor is
going to be the max
in this subtree, which
happens to be a, n, a.
My successor is going to be
the min in this subtree, which
happens to be a, n, n.
And so I find what I want.
How long does it
take me to do that?
Well, if I store
subtree mins and maxs,
then I just have to
walk down the tree.
That will take order
P time to walk down.
And then, once I'm
at a node, I've
got to do a predecessor
or successor in the node.
So there are two issues.
One is, given a node, how do
you know which way to walk down?
And then, when you're
done, how do you
do predecessor in a node?
It's the fundamental question.
Now, this is something
we spent a lot of time
doing in, say, fusion trees.
That was the big challenge.
So this is not
really so trivial--
how do I represent a node?
One way to make it trivial is
to assume that the alphabet is
constant size, like two.
Then, of course,
there's nothing to do.
It's a binary trie.
You look at 0, you look at 1.
You can figure out
anything you need to do
if the alphabet is constant.
But things get interesting
if you imagine,
well, the alphabet
is some parameter,
we don't know how big it is.
It might be substantial.
So let's think about
how you might represent
a trie or the node of a trie.
Let's call this trie
node representation.
Any suggestions?
What are the obvious ways to
represent the node of a trie?
Nothing fancy.
I have three obvious
answers, at least.
AUDIENCE: Array.
ERIK DEMAINE: Array.
Good.
That was my number one.
Any more?
That's I think the most obvious.
AUDIENCE: Tree.
ERIK DEMAINE: Tree.
Good.
Do a binary search tree.
Or?
AUDIENCE: Hash table.
ERIK DEMAINE: Hash table.
Good.
So for each of them we
have query time and space.
If I use an array,
meaning I have--
let's say, for a through z--
I have a pointer that either
is null or points to the child.
This is going to be really
fast because they're at a node.
If I want to know, I just
look at that i-th letter
in my pattern P. I
say, oh, it's a j.
So I look at the j
position and I follow it.
You might wonder, how do I
do predecessor and successor?
Well, this is a
static data structure.
So for every cell,
if it's null, I
can store the predecessor
and successor in the node.
With no more space.
This is Sigma space per node.
So the amount of space is T
Sigma, which is not so great.
But the query is fast,
query is order P time.
BST.
The idea of the BST
is instead of having
a node that has some pointers,
some of which may be absent,
let's expand it out into
something like this.
Actually, I'll use colors.
This will make life a little
bit cleaner in a moment.
Because we are going to
modify this approach.
So let's say that the pointers
you care about are red.
Those are the actual letter
pointers you want to do.
So the idea is to expand
out this high degree node
into binary nodes.
You put appropriate keys in here
so you can do a binary search.
And then, eventually, you get
down to where you need to go.
This structure has
high log Sigma.
So the query time is
going to be P log Sigma.
So that goes up a
little bit, not perfect.
But the space now
becomes linear,
so that's an improvement.
Ideally, we'd like the
best of both of these--
optimal query time, optimal
space, linear space.
And hash tables achieve that.
They give you order P
query and order T space.
Again, the issue is some of
these cells are absent so
don't use an array.
That's like a direct
mapped hash table.
Use a hash table, use hashing.
That way you can use linear
space per node, however many
occupied children there are.
What is T here, by the way?
T is the sum of the
lengths of the T i's--
because here we're
storing multiple T i's.
Or it's the number of
nodes in the tree, which,
if your strings happen to
have a lot of common prefixes,
the number of nodes in
the trie could be smaller
than that, but not in general.
What's the problem
with the hash table?
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yes.
For the BST, we need to
store some keys in this node.
That lets you do
a binary search.
For example, every
node could store
the max in the left subtree--
just within this
little tree, though.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: It
is order T. Sorry,
I see-- why is it
not O T Sigma space?
You're only storing
one letter here,
so that fits in a single
word, and two pointers.
So every node only
takes constant space.
It's only T space, not T Sigma.
Other questions?
Or answers?
There's a problem with hashing--
doesn't actually solve the
problem we want to solve.
It doesn't solve predecessor.
Because hashing mixes up
the order of the nodes.
This is the problem
we had with--
what's it called-- signature
sort, which hashed,
it messed up, it permuted
all the things in the nodes
and so you didn't know--
I mean, in a hash table,
you can't solve predecessor.
That's what the
predecessor problem is for.
I guess you could try to
throw a predecessor data
structure in here.
Actually, I hadn't
thought of that before.
So we could use y-fast
tries or something.
And we would get
order T space and--
I guess, with high
probability, this
is also with high probability--
we get order P log
log Sigma, I guess.
Because I use Van Emde Boas.
I'm going to have to call
it 3.5, Van Emde Boas.
So that would be
another approach.
So hashing will not
do a predecessor.
We'll do exact search, which is
still an interesting problem.
Might give you some
strings I want to know--
is this string in your set?
But it won't solve the
predecessor problem.
So this is an interesting
solution-- hashing--
but not quite what we want.
And Van Emde Boas doesn't
quite do what we want either.
It improves over
the BST approach
but we get another log in there.
But it's still not order
P. I kind of like order P.
Or at least, instead of
order P times log log Sigma,
I kind of like order
P plus log Sigma.
And order P plus
log Sigma is known.
So that's what I want
to tell you about.
And this is normally
done with a structure
called trays, which is
a portamento, I guess,
of tree and array.
Somewhere in there there's
a tree and an array,
so it's a bit of
an awkward word.
But Those are developed by
Koplowitz and Lewenstein,
in 2006, a fairly
recent innovation.
I'll have this number 6--
trays, achieve order P plus
log Sigma and order T space.
So this is pretty good.
And they will do predecessor
and successor-- definitely
an improvement over the BST.
It's open whether you could
do order P plus log log Sigma.
This is as far as I can tell,
no one has worked on this.
Maybe we will work on it today.
So something to think about--
whether you could
get the best of all
of these worlds for predecessor.
There's a lower bound-- you
need to spend at least log log
Sigma time.
Because even if you
try as a single node,
you have the
predecessor lower bound.
And we know log log universe
size is the best you
can do in this regime.
So that's where we're going.
Instead of describing
trays, though, I'm
going to describe
a new way to do
it, which has never
been seen before
in any class or anywhere.
Because it's brand new.
It's developed by Martin
Farach-Colton, who
did the LCA and the
level ancestor structures
that we saw in last class.
And he just told it to
me and it's really cool
so we're going to cover it.
A simpler way to get
this same bound of trays.
And the first thing
we're going to do
is use a weight balanced BST.
This will achieve P plus log
k query and linear space.
k, remember, is the
number of strings
that we're storing, so it's the
number of leaves in the trie.
So it's not quite as
good as P plus log Sigma
but it's going to be a warm up.
We're going to to do this and
then we're going to improve it.
Remember weight balanced trees,
we talked about them way back
in lecture 3, I believe.
There is an issue of
what is the weight.
And typically, you say,
the weight of a subtree
is the number of
nodes in the subtree.
I'm going to change
that slightly and say,
the weight of a subtree is
the number of descendant
leaves in the subtree,
not the number of nodes,
because it's log k.
We really care about the
number of leaves down there.
There could be long
paths here which
we are not so excited about.
We really care about how
many leaves are down there.
Like the weight of this
node here is three--
there's three leaves below it.
You may recall
weight balanced BSTs
trying to make the weight
of the left subtree
within a constant factor of the
weight of the right subtree.
Because we're static,
we can be even simpler
and say, find the
optimal partition.
So we're thinking
about this approach--
idea of expanding a large degree
node into some binary tree.
We have a choice of
what binary tree to use.
With three nodes it may
be not many choices-- that
could be this or it could
be a straight this way
or a straight line that way.
Those are different.
And if one of these
guys is really heavy,
one of these children
is really heavy,
you want to put it
closer to the root.
So that's what
we're going to do.
Let me draw it this way.
That's kind of an array.
But what this array
represents is for a node--
so here's my node, it
has lots of children.
Some of these are
heavy, some of them
are light, lighter than others.
We don't know how
they're distributed.
But they're ordered, we
have to preserve the order.
What this is
supposed to represent
is the total number of
leaves in this subtree.
So the total number
of leaves here.
And then I'm going to partition
this rectangle into groups
corresponding to these sizes.
So these are small, medium,
small, little less than medium,
big, and then small.
Something like that.
So these horizontal
lengths correspond
to the number of
leaves in these things,
correspond to the
weight of my children.
So I look at that
and I say, well,
what I'd really like
to do is split this
in the middle, which
is, maybe, here.
I say, OK, well,
then I'll split here.
That's pretty close
to the middle.
So my left subtree will
consist of these guys,
my right subtree will
consist of these guys.
And then I recurse--
over here I've
split at the middle,
I find the thing that's
closest to the middle.
Over here I've
split at the middle,
I find the thing that's
closest to the middle.
It's pretty much determined.
So my root node
corresponds to this one.
It's going to partition here.
So over on the right,
there's going to be--
here's going to be the
big tree and then here
is the small tree.
So this small tree
corresponds to this one.
This big tree corresponds
to this interval.
Then on the left we've got
four things we need to store.
So these are the red
pointers that we had before.
Then over on the left, we're
going to have a partition.
And then there's going
to be two guys here.
It doesn't really matter
how we store them.
It's something like this.
There is medium and small.
And then over on the left,
we also have two guys.
So it's going to be,
again, something like this.
You got medium and small.
So you see how that worked.
Our main goal was to make this
big guy as close to the root
as possible.
It was the biggest and that's
basically what happened.
This one is really big.
And we couldn't quite put
it as a child of the root
because it appeared
in the middle,
but we could put it as a
grandchild at the root.
In general, if you have
a super heavy child,
it will always become a child
or grandchild of the root.
So in constant number of
traversals you'll get there.
Now again, you fill in
these nodes with some keys
so you can do a binary search.
But now the binary
search might go faster
than log Sigma, which
is what we had before.
And indeed, you can prove
that this really works well.
So what's the claim?
Claim is every two
edges you follow either
advance one letter in P--
these are the red edges
that we want to follow.
So if we follow a
red edge, then we've
made progress to the next node.
So this would be
following a red edge.
Or we reduce the number of
candidate to T i's by 2/3
or, I guess, to 2/3
of its original value.
So we lose a third
of the strings.
That's what I'd like to claim.
And it's not too
hard to see this.
You have to imagine all of
these possible partitions.
It's a little bit awkward.
The idea is the following.
If you take one
of these arrays--
this view of all the leaves
just laid out on the line--
you say, well, I'd like
to split in half and half.
But that will never happen
unless I'm really lucky.
So let's think about
this one third splitting.
If I were able to cut anywhere
in here, then in one step,
actually, I would achieve
this 2/3 reduction.
I'd lose a third of the nodes.
If I end up cutting here,
for example, then either I
go to the left and I lost
almost 2/3 of the nodes,
or I go to the
right and I at least
lost this one third of the notes
or one third of the leaves,
I should say.
So that would be
a good situation
if I got some cut in here.
But it might be there is no
possible cut I can make in here
because there's a giant child
in here that has more than one
third of the nodes.
It would have to span
all the way across here.
So I can't make any
cuts, I can only
cut between child boundaries.
In that situation,
you make this--
well, this is when I need to
follow two edges, not one.
When there's a super big
child like that, as we said,
it will become a
grandchild of the root.
So it will be--
there's the root and then
here is the giant tree.
And then there's going to be
the other stuff here and here.
So after I go down to either
one step or two steps,
I will either get here--
sorry, more red chalk,
this was a red point.
Now, this is going to a child.
So if I went there,
I'm happy in two steps.
I advance one letter in P.
Or in two steps, I went here
or I went here.
And this was a huge
amount of the nodes,
this is at least a
third of the nodes.
Again, if I end up
here or end up here,
I lost 2/3 of the
candidate leaves.
I mean, I lost one third
of the candidate leaves,
leaving 2/3 of them.
If this happens, I charged
to this order P term.
And if the other
situation happens,
I charge the log k term--
because I can only reduce k
by a factor of 2/3--
order log k times.
This implies order
p plus log k search.
So a very simple idea.
Just change the way we do BSTs.
And we get, in some
cases, a better bound.
But not in all
cases because maybe
P plus log k might be bigger
than P times log Sigma.
And k and Sigma are kind of
incomparable, so we don't know.
That's where method
5 comes in, which
is our good friend
from last class--
leaf trimming and indirection.
So we're going to use
this idea of finding--
we're going to cut below
maximally deep nodes
with the right number
of descendants in them.
So we need at least
Sigma descendants.
It could just be descendants
or descendant leaves,
doesn't actually matter.
Let me draw a picture, maybe.
This is pretty much
what we did before,
except before this magic number
was log n that we needed or 1/2
log n or something.
Now it's going to be
Sigma that we need.
So it is we find these
maximally deep nodes--
these dots-- that
have at least--
I guess, there is really
multiple things hanging off
here.
In general, it could be
several things hanging off.
But the total number
of descendants
of each of these nodes
is at least Sigma.
So what that implies
is that the number
of these dots, the number of
the leaves in the top tree--
so up here-- number of leaves
is at most T over Sigma.
Because we can charge each
of these nodes to Sigma
descendants in each of them.
So that's good because it
says we can use method 1--
the simple array method--
which is fast but spacious.
But if our new size of the trie
gets divided by a Sigma factor,
then this turns
out to be linear.
So up here we use method 1.
Now, you got to be a little
careful because we can't
use method 1 on all the nodes.
We can definitely
use it on the leaves
because there aren't
too many leaves.
That means we can also use it on
the number of branching nodes.
Number of branching
nodes is also
going to be, at
most, T over Sigma
because it's actually
one fewer branching node
than there are leaves.
So great, I can use
arrays on the leaves,
I can use arrays on
the branching nodes.
I can't use it on the
non-branching nodes.
Non-branching nodes are nodes
with a single descendant
and everything else is null.
What do I do for those nodes?
Very difficult. I just store
that one pointer in a storage
label.
I guess you could think
of that as method 2
in a very trivial case.
You see-- is this
the right label?
Yes or no.
So this is the
non-branching nodes.
Non-branching top nodes--
I will use method 2.
So I guess this is really--
well, for these
guys I use method 1,
for these guys I use method 1.
So I can afford all this.
This will take order T space.
And it will be fast because
either I'm using arrays
or I really don't
have any work to do,
and so it doesn't
really matter what I do.
But except I can't use
arrays because they
would be too spacious.
So that handles the top.
Now, the issue is, what about
these bottom structures?
The bottom structures--
what do we know?
They have to have
less than Sigma nodes,
less than Sigma descendants.
Also less than Sigma leaves.
So in other words,
in these trees
we have k less than Sigma.
Well, then we can
afford to use method 4.
Because our whole goal is to get
k down to Sigma in this bound.
So in the bottom
trees, we use method 4.
Method 4 was always
linear space.
And the issue was we
paid P plus log k.
But now in here, k is less
than Sigma in these trees.
So that means we get order
P plus log Sigma query time.
And that's the best we know how
to do if you want predecessor
at the nodes.
So it matches this tray
bound in pretty easy way.
Just to apply weight balanced,
clean things up a little bit.
But only do that at the
leaves and everywhere up
here, basically.
Except the non-branching
nodes use arrays.
So for the most part arrays
and then, at the bottom,
you use weight balance.
This is how you ought
to represent a trie.
If you want to preserve
the order of the children,
this is the best
we know how to do.
If you don't want to preserve
order, just use a hash table.
So it depends on
the application.
One fun application of
this is string sorting.
It's not a data
structures problem
so I don't want to spend
too much time on it.
But you use this trie data
structure to sort strings.
You just throw in a string
and then throw in a string.
We didn't talk about dynamic
tries but it can be done.
And if you throw it,
you just sort of find
where you fall off and
then add the thing.
Now, you have to maintain
all this funky stuff
but weight balanced trees can
be made dynamic and indirection
can be made dynamic.
So you end up with this sort
of simple incremental scheme.
You end up with T
plus k log Sigma
to sort k strings of total size
T with alphabet size Sigma.
This is good.
If I used, for example,
merge sort to sort strings,
it's going to be very bad.
It's going to be something like
T times k times log something.
We didn't really
care about the log.
T times k is bad.
That's because comparing strings
could potentially take T time.
And then there's k of them.
But this is linear.
This is the sum of the
lengths of the strings.
There's this extra little term.
But most of the time that's
going to be dominated
by the length of the strings.
So that's a good way to
sort strings using tries.
Tries by themselves, I mean this
is about all there is to say.
So let's move on to suffix
trees and compressed tries.
Now, we actually did compressed
tries in the signature sort
lecture.
Actually, why don't
I go over here?
So tries-- branches were
labeled with letters.
That's still going to be
true for a compressed trie.
But as we saw in that
lecture, in compressed trie
we're going to get rid of
the non-branching nodes.
So idea with the compressed
trie is very simple--
just contract non-branching
paths into a single edge.
This is our example of a trie.
We're just going to modify
it to make a compressed trie.
Here we have a
non-branching path.
We have to follow an a, and
then we have to follow an n.
There's no point in
having this node.
You might as well just
have a single edge
that says a-n on it.
So we go from here,
from the root.
We're going to have
an edge that says a-n.
And in some sense, the
key of this child is a.
If you're starting up
here and you want to know
which way should I go, you
should only go this way
if your first letter is a.
After that, your next
letter better be n,
otherwise you fell off the tree.
So that's the
compression we're doing.
Now, here we have-- this
is a branching node,
so that node we keep intact.
This is an n, this is an a here.
But here it's non-branching.
Let me draw this a
little bit longer.
In reality, it's
just a single edge.
And again, the key is a, and
then you must have a $ sign
on afterwards.
Then you reach a
leaf, the first leaf.
If we follow the n branch--
this is branching, so
that node is preserved.
If I go this way, it's a
$ sign and I reach a leaf.
If I go this way it's an a that
must be followed by a $ sign,
so that's a leaf.
And if I go this way, it must
be an e, followed by a $ sign,
which is a leaf.
Again, these four leaves
can point to these places.
That's a compressed trie.
Pretty obvious.
The nice thing about the
compressed trie is the number--
here we knew the number
of non-branching nodes,
it was at most the
number of leaves.
Over here, the number
of internal nodes
is at most the number of leaves.
So this structure has
order k nodes in total
because we got rid of all
the non-branching nodes.
I guess except the root, the
root might not be branching.
We've got a big O
there to cover us.
And all the things we said
about representing tries here,
you can do the same thing
with a compressed trie.
I need to write
down that 3.5 here.
And in fact, these
results get better because
before order T meant the
number of nodes in the trie.
Now order T will be
the number of nodes
in the compressed trie,
which is actually order k.
So life gets really
good in this world.
I did it in the trie
setting because it's
just simpler to think about.
But really, you would always
store a compressed trie.
There's no point
in storing a trie.
You can still do the
same kinds of searches.
But really, compressed tries
are warm up for suffix trees.
So let's talk
about suffix trees.
Suffix trees are
a compressed trie.
So really they should
be called suffix tries.
And occasionally, people
will call them suffix tries.
But most people call
them suffix trees,
so for consistency I'll
call them trees as well.
But they are tries.
I'm going to introduce
some notation here.
With tries, we are
thinking about lots
of different strings.
In this case, we're going back
to our string matching problem.
We have a single text and we
want to preprocess that text.
But we're going to turn
it into multiple strings
by looking at all
suffixes of the string.
This is Python
notation for everything
from letter i onwards.
And we do that for all i,
so that's a lot of strings.
And we build the
compressed trie over them.
That's the idea.
And to make it work out--
because you remember,
with tries we had to append
$ sign to every string.
In this case, we'd just
have to append $ sign to T,
and then all suffixes
will end with a $ sign.
So that covers
us. $ sign, again,
is a character not
appearing in the alphabet.
And that's it.
So that's a definition.
Let's do an example.
At this point, we going for
this goal of order P query,
order T space.
Suffix trees will be a
way to achieve that goal.
Let's do my favorite
example which is banana.
I had a friend who said, I
know how to spell banana,
I just don't know when to stop.
There's nice pattern to it
and a lot of repeated letters
and so on.
I've got to number
the characters.
He said that when he was like
six, not when he was older.
It's a little harder when
you're writing it on the board
but we all know how to
spell banana, I hope.
I'd got it right, right?
It should be 7 letters,
including the $ sign.
There they are.
So there's a suffix which
is the whole string.
There's a suffix which
is a, n, a, n, a, $ sign.
There is a suffix which
is n, a, n, a, $ sign.
There's a suffix which
is a, n, a, $ sign.
Suffix n, a, $ sign. a, $ sign.
And $ sign.
And empty, I suppose, but we're
not going to store that one.
You don't need to.
Cool.
I'm going to cheat a little
bit and look at my figure
because it is a little
bit of thinking.
One The final challenge
of this lecture
will be construct this
diagram in linear time.
But I'm, just for
now, going to cheat
because it's a little
tricky to do it and get
all the nodes in sorted order.
So that should give it to us.
And then the suffixes.
Here is another color.
6, 5, 3, 1, 0, 4, 2.
Cool.
This I claim is a
suffix tree of banana.
You see the banana substring.
Than the next one is
a, n, a, n, a, $ sign.
Then the next one is
n, a, n, a, $ sign.
Then the next one
is a, n, a, $ sign.
Next one is n, a, $ sign.
Next one is a, $ sign.
And then $ sign.
So that's a nice,
clean representation
of all the suffixes.
And you can see that if
you wanted to search from
the middle of this string--
suppose I want to search
for a nan--
then it's right there.
Just do n, a, n, then I'm done.
This virtual node
in the middle here
along the one third of
the way down the edge,
that represents n-a-n.
And indeed, if you look
at the descendant leaf,
that corresponds to an
occurrence of n-a-n.
If I was going to
look for a-n, I
would do a, n, so
halfway down this edge.
And then this subtree represents
all the occurrences of a-n.
Think about it.
There's two of them--
One that starts at position 3,
one that starts at position 1.
Here's one occurrence
of a-n, here's
another occurrence of a-n.
This works even when
they're overlapping.
If I search for a-n-a,
I would get here.
And then these are the two
occurrences of a-n-a and they
actually overlap each other--
this one and this one.
So this is a great
data structure,
it solves what we need.
It's all substrings searching.
Applications of suffix trees.
Just do a search in the trie
for a particular pattern.
We get subtree representing all
of the occurrences of P and T.
So this is great.
In order P time, walking
down this structure,
I can figure out
all the occurrences.
And then, if I want to
know how many there were,
I could just store
subtree sizes--
number of leaves
below every node.
If I wanted to list
them, I could just
do an in-order traversal.
And I'll even get them in order.
So in particular, if I wanted to
list the first 10 occurrences,
I could store the left-most leaf
from every node, teleport down
to the first occurrence
in constant time.
And then I could just have a
linked list of all the leaves.
So once I find the
first one, I can just
follow until I find, oh,
that's not an occurrence of P.
So I can list the first
k of them in order k time
once I've done the
search of order P time.
So this is really
good searching.
And It's the ideal situation.
You can list any information
you want about all
of the answers in the optimal
time and size of the output.
How big is this data structure?
Well, there are T suffixes,
so k is the size of T.
And when we look at our
trie representations,
our general goal was to get--
here, capital T was
the sum of the lengths.
Well, sum of the
lengths is not good--
that would be quadratic--
sum of the lengths
of the suffixes.
But we also said, or the
number of nodes in the trie.
And we know the number
of leaves in this trie
is exactly the size of T. And so
because it's a compressed trie,
the number of
internal [INAUDIBLE]
is also less than the size of
T. So the total number of nodes
here is order T And
so if we use any
of the reasonable
representations,
we get order T space.
Now, there's one issue which
is, how long does a search for P
cost?
And it depends on
our representation,
it depends how quickly
we can traverse a node.
If we use hashing--
method 3-- use hashing,
then we get order P time.
But the trouble with
hashing is it permutes
the children of every node.
So in that situation,
the leaves will not
be ordered in the same way that
they're ordered in the string.
So if you really want to be
able to find the first five
occurrences of the pattern
P, you can't use hashing.
You can find some
five occurrences
but you will find the
first in the usual ordering
of the string.
So if you really
want the first five
and you want them in order,
then you should use trays--
this method 6 that we used.
6?
5.
If we use trays, then it will
be order P times log Sigma--
sorry, order P plus log Sigma.
That was our query time.
Here, P plus log Sigma.
Small penalty to pay but the
nice thing is then your answers
are represented in order.
No permutation, no
hashing, no randomization.
This is the reason suffix
trees were invented--
they let you do searches fast.
But actually, they let you
do a ton of things fast.
And I want to quickly
give you an overview
of the zillions of things you
can do with the suffix tree.
And then I want to get
to how to build them
in linear time, which has some
interesting algorithms/data
structures.
I already talked
about if you want
to find the first
k occurrences, you
can do that in order k time.
If you want to find the
number of occurrences,
you can do that
in constant time,
just by augmenting
the subtree sizes.
Here's another
thing you could do.
Suppose you have a
very long string.
I mean think of T as
an entire document.
You know, it could be the
Merriam-Webster dictionary
or it could be the web.
We're imagining T to be
the huge data structure.
And then we're able to search
for substrings within that data
structure very fast.
So that's cool.
Here's an interesting puzzle.
What is the longest substring--
what is the longest string that
appears twice on the web?
This is called the longest
repeated substring.
Could be overlapping, maybe not.
Well, you take the web, you
throw it in the suffix tree--
not sure anyone could
actually do that--
but small part of the web.
Dictionary-- this
would be no problem.
Wikipedia would be feasible.
You take Wikipedia, you
throw it in the suffix tree.
And what I'm interested
in is, basically,
a node that has two, at
least two descendant leaves.
And if I'm counting the number
of leaves at every node,
I could just do one pass
over this data structure
and find what are all
the nodes that have
at least two descendant leaves.
That's all the internal nodes.
And then among them I'd also
like to know how deep is it.
Because the depth corresponds
to how long the string is.
This one is a-n-a
so this one has,
I call it, a letter depth of 3.
This one has a
letter depth of 1.
letter depth of 2.
So I just want to find
the deepest node that has
at least two descendant leaves.
In linear time, I could find
the longest repeated substring.
Or I could find the
longest substring that
appears five times or whatever.
I just do one pass
over this thing,
find the deepest node that
has my threshold of leaves.
So that's kind of a
neat thing you can
do in linear time on a string.
Here's another fun one.
Suppose I have
this giant string.
And I just want to compare
two substrings in it.
So here's my giant string.
And suppose I want to measure
how long is the repeated
substring.
So I say, well,
I've got position i,
I've got position j.
Let's say I already know that
they match for a little bit.
I want to know, how
long do they match?
How far can I go to the right
and have them still match?
How could I do that?
Well, I could look at
the suffix starting at i.
That corresponds to
a leaf over here.
And I could look at the
suffix starting at j.
That corresponds
to some other leaf.
And what is the length of
the longest common prefix
of those two suffixes
in the suffix tree?
Three letters-- LCA.
If I take the LCA of those
two leaves-- for example,
I take these two leaves--
the LCA gives me the
longest common prefix.
Then they branch.
So longest common prefix
of these two suffixes
is the letter a, so
it's just length 1.
And again, if I label every
node with the letter depth,
I can figure out exactly
how long these guys match,
even if they overlap.
So in constant time--
because we already
have a constant time LCA query.
Linear space,
constant time query.
Given any two
positions i and j, I
can tell you how long they
match for in constant time.
Boom-- instantaneously.
It's kind of crazy.
So you can do tons of
these queries instantly.
That's one reason why
people care about LCAs,
there are other reasons.
But mostly LCAs were
developed for suffix trees
to answer queries like that.
Got some more.
Why don't I just write--
LCP of one suffix
and another suffix
is equivalent to an LCA query.
And so we can do
that in constant time
after pre-processing.
Here's another one.
Suppose I want to find all
occurrences of T i to j.
So I give you a
substring and I want
to know where does that occur.
The substring is restricted
to come from the text.
Now, this is a little subtle.
Of course, I could solve it
in j minus i plus 1 time.
I just do the search.
But what if I want to
do it in constant time?
Maybe this is a
really big substring.
But I still know it
appears multiple times.
I want to know how many
times does it appear.
I claim I can do this
in constant time.
How?
This is a level ancestor query.
Why is it a level
ancestor query?
If I look at the
suffix starting at i,
and then I just want to
trim off, I want to stop.
Or I don't care about
the entire suffix,
I just want to do that j.
It's like saying, well,
suppose I'm looking
for occurrences of a-n-a.
So I go and I start at the
first occurrence of a-n-a,
which is a-n-a-n-a-$, so this
is the leaf corresponding
to a-n-a.
And then if I want to find
all occurrences of a-n-a,
I just need to go up to the
ancestor that represents a-n-a.
This is what I call a
weighted level ancestor.
That's not quite the
problem we solved
in the last lecture, lecture
15, because now it's weighted.
So it's level ancestor j minus
i of the T i suffix leaf.
So I find this leaf,
which I just have
an array of all the leaves.
Given a suffix, tell me what
leaf it is in the suffix tree.
And then I want to find
the j minus i-th ancestor,
except the edges don't
just have unit length.
So here I want to find
the third ancestor,
except it's really the ancestor
in the compressed trie.
I want to do the j
minus i-th ancestor
in the suffix in
the trie, but what
I have is a compressed tree.
And so these edges are labeled
with how many characters
are on them and I got
to deal with that.
Fortunately, the data structure
we gave for a level ancestor--
which was constant time
query, linear space--
can be fairly easily
adapted to weights.
Not quite in
constant time though.
It can be solved
in log log n time.
And I think that's optimal.
Because if your thing is
a single path with maybe
the occasional branch, then
finding your i-th ancestor here
is like solving a
predecessor problem.
Because you say, well,
from the i-th position up,
I want to know what
is the previous--
I want to round
up or round down.
So I want to do a
predecessor or a successor
on this straight line.
And so for a
predecessor you need
log log time for
the right parameters
and this can be achieved.
And the basic idea is you
use ladder decomposition,
just like before.
But now a ladder can't be
represented by an array
because there are lots of
absent places in the array.
Now instead, use a predecessor,
use a Van Emde Boas
to represent a ladder.
So that's basically all you do.
Van Emde Boas
represents a ladder.
That's what you do
in the top structure.
Remember, we had
indirection, leaf trimming,
top was this thing,
ladder decomposition.
You Bottom was look up tables.
The other problem is you can't
use lookup tables anymore
because in one of
these tiny trees
you could have a
super long path.
It's non-branching,
they got compressed.
And you can't
afford to enumerate
all possible situations.
It's kind of annoying.
So instead of using lookup
tables-- this was actually
an idea from some students
in this class last time
I taught this material--
they said, oh, well, instead
of using a lookup table, you
can use ladder decomposition.
So down here, in
the compressed tree,
we have log n different nodes.
If you use ladder decomposition
on that thing-- but not
the hybrid structure.
Remember, we used jump
pointers plus ladders.
Jump pointers still
work here, just
you have to round them
to a different place.
Down here, I'm not
going to try to do
jump pointers plus ladders.
I'll just do ladders.
And remember, just ladders
gave us a log n query time.
But now n is log T. And so
we get log log T query time.
And that's, basically,
all you have to do.
So you're always jumping
to the top of a ladder.
You'll only have to
traverse log log T ladders.
The very last ladder
you might have
to do a predecessor query that
will cost you log log log T.
But overall, it will
be log log T time just
by this kind of tweak to our
level ancestor data structure.
So I thought that was
kind of a fun connection.
This is the reason, essentially,
level ancestors were developed.
And people use them
because you can
do these kinds of things
in nearly constant time,
even if the substring is huge.
So maybe I know ahead
of time all the queries
I might want to do.
I just throw them into the
text, just add them in there.
Then I've cut these
substrings, they're now
represented in the suffix tree.
Now any substring I want
to query in log log n time,
I can find all the
occurrences of that string,
even if the substring is huge.
So if you know what
queries you want,
you can preprocess
them and solve them
even faster than order P time.
Cool.
Another thing you can do is
represent multiple documents.
And that's what I was
sort of getting at there.
If you have multiple
documents-- say,
you're storing the
entire web or Wikipedia.
Like there's multiple pages.
You want to separate them.
All you need to do is say,
OK, I'll take my first string
and then put a special
$ sign after it.
Then take my second string,
put a special $ sign after it.
And take my k-th string and
Just concatenate them with
different $ signs in between
them.
Then build the suffix tree on
this thing which I'll call T
So you can use the same
suffix tree data structure,
but now, in some sense,
you're representing
all of these documents and
all the ways they interweave.
Because there are
some shared substrings
here that are shared by
this, and this, and whatever.
And those will be represented
in the same structure.
Or I can do a search and
then I've effectively
found all the documents
that contain it.
One issue, though.
Suppose, I want to find all
the documents containing
the word MIT or something.
Maybe all k of them match,
maybe one document matches,
maybe two documents match.
Suppose, two documents match.
The first document mentions
MIT a billion times.
The second document
has MIT in it once.
Then suffix trees
are kind of annoying
because they will find that
billion and one matches
as a subtree.
But if I just want to know the
answer, oh, these two documents
match, I'd like to do
that in order 2 time,
not order billion time,
to use technical terms.
And that is called the document
retrieval problem or a document
retrieval data structure.
This is a problem considered
by M. Krishnan in 2002.
Document retrieval you can
do an order P plus number
of documents matching.
So if I want to list all
the documents that match,
I could do an order the number
of documents that match,
not the order of a number of
occurrences of the string.
So I still got to do the
P search in the beginning,
and then this is better.
And the funny thing is the
solution to this data structure
uses RMQ, range minimum
queries, from last lecture.
So let me tell you how it works.
It's actually very simple.
And then I think we'll move on
to how to build a suffix tree.
So document retrieval.
Here's what we're going to do.
Remember, these different $
signs i represent different
documents.
I want to remember
which suffixes
came from the same document.
So at every $ sign i, I
want to store the number
of the previous $ sign i.
Let's suppose, the suffixes,
when they get to one of the $
signs, I can just stop, I
don't have to store the rest,
I'm going to throw away.
Whenever I hit a $ sign, I
will stop the suffix tree.
That way, the $ signs
really are leaves,
all of them now become leaves.
So I don't really care
about a suffix that
goes all the way through here.
I just want the
suffix to the $ sign,
as it represents the
individual documents.
So $ sign i's are leaves.
And I want each of them just
to store a pointer, basically,
to the previous one of the
same type, the same $ sign i.
It came from the same document.
Now, here's the idea.
I did a search, I
got down to a node,
and now there's this
big subtree here.
And this subtree has a
bunch of leaves in it,
those represent all the
occurrences of the pattern P.
And let's suppose that
those leaves are numbered.
I'm numbering the leaves
from 1 to n, I guess.
Then in here, the leaves
will be an interval--
interval l, comma, n.
And the trouble is a lot of
these have the same label $
sign i.
And I just want to
find the unique ones.
How do I do that?
What we do is find the first
occurrence of $ sign i for each
i.
I could just find the first
occurrence of $ sign i for each
i.
I'd then only have to pay order
number of distinct documents,
then we'll have to pay for
every match within the document.
Now, one way to define
the first $ sign i is--
that's a $ sign i
whose stored value--
we said we store the leaf number
of the previous $ sign i--
whose stored value
is less than l.
So we find some position here.
If the previous
guy is less than l,
that means it was the
first of that type.
If we store this, that's
definition of being first.
So in this interval, I want to
find $ sign i's that have very
small stored values.
How would I find
the very best one?
Range minimum query.
So we do a range minimum
query on l, comma, n.
If there's any firsts in
there, this will find it.
Find, let's say, a position
m with the smallest
possible stored value.
If the stored number
is less than l,
then output that answer.
And then recurse on the
remaining intervals.
So there's going to be from l
to m minus 1 and m plus 1 to n.
So we find the best
candidate, the minimum.
That's minimum sorted value.
If anything is going to be
less than l, that would be it.
If it is less than l, we output
it, then we recurse over here
and we recurse over here.
At some point this will
stop finding things.
We're going to do
another RMQ over here.
Might not find anything, then
we just stop that recursion.
But the number of
recursions we have to do
is going to be equal to
the number of documents
that match, maybe plus 1.
So we achieved this bound
using RMQ because RMQ
we can do in constant time with
appropriate pre-processing.
Now, the RMQ is over an array.
It's over this array of stored
values indexed by leaves.
And this idea of
taking the leaves
and writing them down in order
is actually something we need.
It's called a suffix array.
We're going to use this
alternate representation
of suffix trees in
order to compute them.
Suffix arrays in some sense
are easier to think about.
The idea with the
suffix array is
to write down all the
suffixes, sort them.
This is conceptual.
Imagine you take
all these suffixes.
Their total size
is quadratic in T
so you'd never actually
want to do this.
But just imagine
writing them down,
sorting them lexically using
our string sorting algorithms.
And then we can't
represent them explicitly
because it would be too big.
Just write down their index,
just store the indices.
Let's do this for banana.
Banana's over here.
It'll make my life
a little harder.
Actually, they're already
here in sorted order.
If dollar sign, I'm supposing,
is first, first suffix is $,
then a-$, then a-n-a-$, then
a-n-a-n-a-$, then banana,
then n-a-$, then n-a-n-a-$.
I'll just write
that down over here.
$, a-$, a-n-a-$, a-n-a-n-a-$,
then banana, then n-a-$,
then n-a-n-a-$.
If you look at these, they're
indeed in sorted order-- $,
a's, b's, n's.
Everything is sorted
here lexically.
Now, I can't store this
because it's quadratic size.
Instead, I just write down the
numbers that are down there.
This was the sixth suffix, it
was starting at position 6.
Then 5, then 3, then 1, then 0--
that's everything--
then 4, then 2.
This thing is the suffix array.
It also has linear size.
It's just a permutation on the
suffix labels, suffix indices.
I still want to
tell you about it.
There's some other
information that's
helpful to write down
about the suffix array.
It's called longest common
prefix information, LCP.
The idea is to look at adjacent
elements in the suffix array.
In some sense, this represents
the same information, right?
Our whole goal is to
sort the suffixes.
If we could do this,
then, as we'll see,
we can also build this.
And this is sort of
what we really want.
The suffix array by
itself is pretty good
if you add in LCP information.
LCP is-- what is the longest
common prefix of these two
suffixes?
In this case, 0.
In this case, one letter.
In this case, three
letters match.
So here the value is 3.
And the next one,
zero letters match.
Next one, zero letters match.
Next one, two letters match.
So this is another array
you could store here--
0, 1, 3, 0, 0, 2.
AUDIENCE: Longest common prefix?
ERIK DEMAINE: Longest common
prefix of the suffixes.
Because each of these
is a suffix but here
we're interested in how
long they match for.
I claim if you have this suffix
array and this LCP information,
you can build this structure.
Anyone wants to tell me how
to build this using this?
It's a one word or two word
answer that we saw, I think,
last class.
But we saw a lot of things
last class, so it's maybe not
obvious.
Magic words are Cartesian tree.
Cartesian tree was how we
converted RMQ into LCA,
I think.
Yeah?
Which was you take the
minimum value in the array,
make that the root, and then
recurse on the two sides.
So a Cartesian tree
of the LCP array,
basically, gives you
this transformation.
The minimum values
here are the 0's.
Now, before we just broke
ties, we picked an arbitrary 0,
put it at the root.
Now I want to take all the
0's, put them at the root.
If I do that, I get
three 0's at the root
and then I have
everything in between.
So there's nothing
left of the first 0.
Then next one,
there's these guys
and the mins are going
to be 1 and then 3.
So here I'm going to get a
1 when I recurse and then 3.
There's nothing in
between these 0's.
And after the last
0, there's a 2.
So this would be the Cartesian
tree, a slightly different
version where we
don't break ties,
we take all the
mins simultaneously,
put them at the root.
Now, does that look
like this thing?
Yeah.
Everything except the leaves.
[INAUDIBLE] are
missing at the leaves.
The leaves are represented
by these values.
Just visit them in order
here, do an inner traversal
of the missing pointers here.
We're going to get 6, and
then 5, and then 3 and then 1,
and then 0, and
then 4, and then 2.
Now, the meaning of these
values is slightly different.
Maybe I should
circle them in red.
These leaves are just
like these leaves.
They're exactly the labels we
wrote down in the same order.
These numbers are
slightly different.
What they represent
are letter depths.
The letter depth of this node
is 0, letter depth of this node
is 1, letter depth
of this node is 3.
That's what I wrote here--
1, 3, 2.
This one says, 2.
These LCPs are exactly
the letter depth.
That's how far down
the tree you are.
Once you have this structure
and the letter depth,
you can very easily
put in these labels.
I won't say how to do that.
But in linear time,
if I could build
the suffix array plus the LCPs,
I could build suffix tree.
So our real goal is to build
this information, these two
arrays.
If we could do it
in linear time,
we'd get a suffix
tree in linear time.
So that is what
remains to be done.
We're going to do--
not quite linear time.
If you want a
nicely sorted suffix
tree where all the
children are labeled here--
so in particular, if I
just had a single node,
I have to be able to sort
the letters in the alphabet.
However long that takes.
Maybe it's a small
alphabet and you
can do linear time sorting
by radix sort or whatever.
However long that
takes, we do it once.
Then the rest will
be order T time.
Here's how we do it.
First step-- sort the alphabet.
This will turn out to be
more interesting than you
might think.
I'll come back to it.
Second step--
replace each letter
by its index in
the sorted order.
This sounds boring but it
will be useful for later.
Third step-- the big idea.
This is an algorithm by
Karkkainen and Sanders,
from 2003.
The problem was first
solved in this running time
by Martin Farach-Colton,
our good friend.
But then it got simplified.
So I'll tell you a little
bit about that in a moment.
And there going to be
a lot of writing here.
The idea here is we're going
to take the 3i-th letter,
3i plus first, 3i
plus second letter,
concatenate them into a
single triple letter--
think of it as a single letter.
And then just do that for all i.
So it's like I take
these guys, make them
one letter, these guys,
make them one letter.
Now, I could start at 0,
or I could start at 1,
or I could start at 2.
Do them all.
So this is going to be 3i
plus 1, 3i plus 2, 3i plus 3.
And this one is going to be 3i
plus 2, 3i plus 3, 3i plus 4.
We're going to do
this to recurse.
But the point is, if
I want to represent
all the suffixes
of T, suffix could
start at a position 0 mod
3, or position 1 mod 3,
or position 2 mod 3.
So if I could sort all the
suffixes of these guys,
I would effectively sort all
the suffixes of the original T.
This tripling up doesn't
really change things,
up to like plus 1 or 2.
Next, I believe, is recursion.
I'm going to take T0 and
T1 and concatenate them.
This thing has size 2/3 n.
It has number of characters
2/3 n because each of them
has a third of the
number of characters.
Of course, all the
information is still there,
which is kind of weird.
But if we treat this as
a single character, which
then has a 1/3 n, we can't
afford to recurse on all three.
We can only afford to recurse
on two out of the three
because then we're going to get
a recurrence of the form T of n
is T of 2/3 n plus order n.
And this is geometric,
so it's order n.
That's how we're going
to get linear time
after the first sort.
If this was 3/3 n, then
this would be n log n.
We don't want to do that.
So that's what I can afford.
Now I've got to deal with it.
What this tells me is,
the sorted order of all
the suffixes of T0 and
T1, all the suffixes
starting at positions
that are 0 or 1 mod 3.
Next thing we'd like to do
is sort the suffixes of T2.
We can do that, I
claim, by radix sort.
How do we do that?
Well, if you look
at a suffix T 2i,
this is the same thing as
T from 3i plus 2 onwards.
Which we can think of as
that first character, comma,
the next character onwards.
Sorry, that's the angle bracket.
And this thing is, basically,
T0 of i plus 1 onwards.
So if I strip off
the first letter,
then I get a suffix
that I know about.
I know the sorted order
of all the T0 suffixes.
So this is really just
a-- you can think of this
as a two character value.
There's a single
character from Sigma
here, which we've
already reduced down to--
this is an integer between
0 and Sigma minus 1.
This thing you can do the same
thing with these recursive
values.
So you've just got two values.
Small.
You can radix sort
them in linear time.
And then we will have sorted
T2 suffixes because we already
knew the order of these guys.
One more thing, which we have
to merge suffixes of T0 and T1
with suffixes of T2.
And this is where
we use the fact
that there are three of these
things and not two of them.
This is a weird case where three
way divide and conquer works.
Two way divide and
conquer is what
Farach-Colton did originally.
It's much more complicated
because of this merge step.
Merge gets painful.
I claim this merging
is easy because merging
is linear time, provided your
comparison is constant time.
So if I need to compare a
T0 suffix with a T2 suffix,
if I want to do
that comparison, I
strip off the first
letter from this one.
It turns into a T1 suffix,
the first character
plus a T1 suffix.
If I strip out the first
character of this one,
it turns into the first
character and then a T0 suffix.
And these things I know how
to compare because I already
sorted T0, comma, T1.
If I need to compare T1
suffix with the T2 suffix,
how do I do it?
I strip off the first
two letters of this one,
I get a T0 suffix.
I strip off the first
two letters of this one,
I get a T1 suffix.
I can't strip off one letter
because this would turn it
into a T2 and I don't
know how to compare T2
to other things,
that's the whole point.
I guess, it's a T2
versus a T0, if I
did that, which is this case.
But here, I strip
off two letters,
I get something I
know how to compare.
This technique does not work
if you only have two things.
It only works if you have
three things because they're
sort of these situations.
So constant time.
By comparing these little
tuples, the first character
or two plus the remaining
suffix, I can do the comparator
and merge.
And then if I can do that,
everything is linear time.
The only interesting thing
is how do I sort the alphabet
when I recurse?
And for that, you
use radix sort.
So the first time,
you pay sort of Sigma.
We don't know how long
that takes, depends
on your alphabet.
But every following
recursion it's a radix
sort because you have a triple
of values, each of which
is small.
And so you can do
it in linear time.
Because there's only
three digits to the thing
you're sorting.
So overall, this is a
recursive algorithm.
It gives you linear
time because you're
making one recursive
call of 2/3 the size.
Pretty clever and simple.
And that's suffix trees
and how you build them.
Versus you get suffix arrays,
you can do the same thing
and get LCP information
at the same time,
it's written in the nodes.
Then you get suffix trees.
And then you're done.